that's a brilliant evil question it's
evil I've asked so many people this
question no one's ever wanted to answer
it well here I am
Russell Brand is one of the most famous
comedians in the world
he's one of the most unmissable
performers on the planet you don't want
to be around when the laughter stops
your earliest years are particularly
hard to read
drugs and self-harm your mother's
illnesses
how do we go on the Journey of changing
wow this is proper Diary of a CEO stuff
there is deep spiritual appetite within
all of us for connection but we have a
culture that is predicated upon
individualism and materialism my initial
solution to feeling disconnected and
lonely was to try and become famous if
you are using impermanent means to
achieve a permanent solution you can
only fail but what I would say is is in
that loneliness in that sense of I'm not
good enough I'm worthless are all the
ingredients of success because it is
sadly a gift to you what could I have
added to ten-year-old Russell's life do
you think that would have made him feel
valued
you are enough you are sufficient we are
going to be okay
what told you otherwise
[Music]
Russell Brand is one of the most
fascinating individuals I have ever
spoken to a former self-harming heroin
addict
self-confessed narcissist bulimic that
craved Fame and attention and was so
addicted to sex that he slept with five
women a day that married Katy Perry
three months after meeting her
and then divorced her with a text
message
have you ever felt that subtle feeling
that the way you're living is not quite
right that's something somewhere is out
of balance that you're not living your
life as that human somewhere inside you
should be living their life
the Russell Brand that sits before me
today can relate and he's found a new
cure for that feeling a better way to
handle pain a new blueprint to live by
which he believes that you and me and
all of us will eventually realize
through failure and frustration we are
all addicts searching for ways to feel
less pain through porn and screens and
sugar and addiction and drugs and
whatever our vices might be but maybe
just maybe maybe Russell is right and
maybe there is a simple cure for all of
us right there in plain sight
[Music]
Russell I read a comment at the top of a
YouTube video that um
of an interview you did and this was the
comment this man is a hero he's truly an
example of transcendence across the
Spectrum from the archetype of
selfishness enthralled by addiction to
complete selfness and self-awareness I
love this man with all of my heart wow
that was a comment left regarding you on
a recent interview you've done now I'm
going to be completely honest with you I
should admit that I wrote that comment I
sometimes I do even though I know I've
written it when I read it back it still
gives me a boost
um I said to you before we started
talking I wanted to talk about
disconnection yeah
disconnection for me in my life started
early
disconnection for me was coming to the
UK from Africa as that the only black
kid went to Plymouth everyone's richer
than me everyone's white
um and that pursuit of filling that void
of whatever it was that shame that
insecurity which is very clearly the
reason I'm sat here yeah what do we need
to know about your childhood how did it
shape the man that sits in front of me
today
I have had a life that has been defined
by addiction
and the addiction and in particular the
models of recovery that are available
for addiction is a convenient framework
for addressing the problems we have in
our age
that are expressed extensively and
identifiably through materialism and
attachment
I'd get attached to stuff
I was when I was a little boy I grew up
in a single parent family just me and my
mum I come from an ordinary background
in Essex grays
ordinariness normalcy
these can be terms that are difficult to
Define
but I think we all know what we mean
when we say a normal ordinary modest
blue-collar background low expectations
State schools we know what images that
conjures
my mum was sick a lot when I was a kid
and my mum was and it was a defining
influence in my life all of us that are
lucky enough to have mothers are going
to be defined by that relationship as
well as the other
parental relationship
I feel like real early on something in
me which I would now because it's almost
impossible Stephen not to reverse
engineer these narratives isn't it and
to thread it through with newly accrued
and acquired wisdom
but I feel that I was looking for
something I feel that there is a deep
spiritual appetite within all of us for
connection the subject that you have
identified as our framing for this
conversation that we are having
but we do not have a culture that
presents us a discourse around
connection we we have a culture that is
predicated upon individualism and
materialism your value and this is I
think across the political spectrum and
even in more compassionate narratives
around identity individualism is still
enshrined as the centrifugal point
so I felt like that I was in a state of
lack I don't know what it is to be a man
I don't know what it is to be a success
I don't know what it is to have power I
don't know what it is I recognize now
even to feel at ease even to feel Serene
even to feel relaxed is probably only by
the time I got clean from crack and
heroin and alcohol that I've noticed
that I'd been in having an anxiety
attack for basically my entire life
when I first told my life story in which
is an ordinary exercise at treatment
centers that help people to get
rehabilitated from chemical dependency
and I was fortunate enough to go to one
when the fella read it chip Summers one
of the first people in recovery I ever
met when he read it he went ah poor
lonely little boy
and I was 27 then
so
I suppose my life has been defined by
addiction and addiction is in part a
lack of connection an attempt to
synthesize the connection to self other
and God God of your own understanding
perhaps understood as a totality a sense
of unity a Unity of force a highest
principle when it says in the Old
Testament worship no other gods than me
the implication I offer is that we are a
species that worships and if you do not
access the Divine you will worship the
Mundial you will worship the profane you
will worship your own identity you will
worship your belongings you will worship
the template Lane Before You by a
culture that once you no wants you that
gets you distracted and relatively dumb
so my initial solution to feeling weak
and disconnected and lonely and somehow
silently brilliant was to try and become
successful was to try and become famous
was to try and have resources to try and
address all of the problems of my
original condition my original condition
culturally and socially as I saw it was
lack of power lack of value lack of
connection lack of influence and what
does our culture tell us is the solution
to this be somebody and my God I'm
talking about a long time ago now I'm
talking about in the 80s and the 90s now
the culture is amplifying that message
100 fold with a million screens in every
direction 50 lenses like the eyes of on
the inside of a fly rather than the
almost 2D experience of lenses that I
grew up with what could I have added to
ten-year-old Russell's life do you think
that would have made him feel valued
10 year old
I reckon mate now that I'm a dad
and you can't be a father to anyone else
until you're a father to yourself
is a sense that who you are is all right
you're all right you don't need to worry
that you are enough you are sufficient
we are going to be okay what told you
otherwise
all conditions though it isn't the broad
cultural message you are insufficient
you will not be sufficient until you
acquire this body these objects this
approval these affiliations I don't even
think it's personal to me like whilst
like you know necessarily our
conversation has to be framed by sort of
biographical detail that's particular to
me don't you find that when you know
anyone's story really that the universal
was there waiting for you that there is
a ubiquity of this message how many
times have you heard people that are
hugely successful say I felt inferior I
didn't feel good enough I wanted to
achieve this I didn't have this or that
it's a like it's a else-wise what could
a young have achieved else-wise what
could Joseph Campbell have achieved were
there not archetypes strewn about US
maps waiting to be discovered
it's true most people that's it here
have achieved phenomenal things are it
starts with a story of not being enough
and you often wonder whether they're
driven or dragged
driven by their own you know because
they're framed in books is driven but in
reality they're being dragged by
insecurities and shame and all of these
things that feeling of not enough
um
your your earliest years are um
particularly particularly
um
hard to read and I when I I'll be
completely when I when I read about the
circumstances of your earliest years I
do see a story that is very
unique in in a sense of self-harm your
mother's um sicknesses and her illnesses
um
and there's that guy underneath there
that knew he was brilliant as you say
believed he was brilliant hmm
brilliant in what way
well
I suppose
and I find this to be quite common to
addicts and alcoholics
there's this
pre-metabolized quality that's waiting
to be activated
now brilliant is obviously a comparative
and relative term
and the training I've been fortunate
enough to receive
prohibits me from leaning too heavily
into a framing like that now like
Superior to better than
but I feel that that I had a sense of a
resource that was waiting to unfold I
was had a sense that there would be a
secondary coordinate that might arrive
in the form of a destination
all energy
the most fundamental level requires
polarity it requires polarity and I
suppose that word parent in and that
word parenthesis another word for
bracketing suggests that you need to be
held in some way you need something
that's going to be able to hold you
now if like me I believe in God Stephen
so the thing that defines me now is I
believe in God and I don't believe that
I have unique access to God or Superior
access to God or that there's this
little set of dances or codes or clothes
that need to be worn to access God more
primarily or more privately I believe
that in an absolute loving God that all
of us have the right to be here that I
don't need no special adornments or
epiphets or epileps or badges or
medallions but it's enough for me to be
one of everybody else back then though
as a little kid when I felt inferior and
broken I just wanted to feel a little
bit special I wanted to feel a little
bit valuable
and
I suppose the first time that I really
felt that was making people laugh doing
a school play at my little school grade
school Bugsy Malone I'm feeling the
overwhelming
terrifying adrenaline and the
accompanying sense of competence that
comes with being able to Corral and
direct that energy when it comes a sense
of purpose revelation
when you ask like you know what could
you have added and what do you mean by
silently brilliant
like
I don't want to feel better than no one
else no more I don't want to feel worse
than anyone else
and I want to participate in other
people's becoming who they are intended
to be there's a beautiful phrase in
recovery you may enjoy we recover the
person we're intended to be that somehow
we can respect individuality Limitless
Limitless diversity while somehow
accepting that there is something
unitive among us something Collective to
be realized and achieved
so I suppose it was my own savoring of
my particularness that I was
experiencing even though and this is no
fault of my parents although I might
analyze my culture I felt that that I
couldn't express it and I didn't know
what value it had and what its use was
it was in util until the culture tells
you it can be monetized or it can be
mobilized in order to
now that framing isn't necessarily one
that would ordinarily gravitate to but
that's the one that is available to that
is the totemism of our culture that's
the Paradigm that we are offered so I
suppose that's the one that many of us
inevitably pursue do you have any
emotional sentiment towards that young
man's circumstances as you look back on
what he the situation he was in and what
he was experiencing
do you feel you feel sorry for him you
know do you feel happy for him what
should you feel anything towards
laterally
due to the principles of recovery
due to the fact that I have mentors I
have peers I have people that look to me
for guidance I have service I have duty
responsibility laterally Stephen
I come to feel Incorporated with that
little boy but if you just spoke to me
10 years ago I doubt I would like to
have heard him referred to I wouldn't
have liked that Specter to have risen a
phantom I'd happily put aside but now
like that little boy like hopefully the
little boy that you described down there
in Plymouth of all places
that famous rock from where they depart
across the oceans that personal
Mayflower Journey he's with me now I
love him and he's like he is a great
asset when I'm dealing with young
vulnerable broken people when people
tell me that they want to end their own
lives and people tell me they self-harm
until people tell me they want to kill
themselves that they can't cope with
life they don't feel that they're good
enough
I'm not phased I can stay 100 present
with that and that is a great gift no
was it was there I think about this a
lot with myself was there another path
to where you are now yeah probably me
probably I mean look you may like you
know you've met a lot of people I know a
lot of people
but for me personally just tell you why
I asked that question I believe that I
had a belief that was
ill-informed by the society I lived in
and I believe I had to pursue that
belief to find out that I was wrong and
have it fail me
well it happened now now it has happened
so the answer is 100 of course
absolutely indefatigably this is the
reality that was designed for you
internally that your Consciousness is
creating this reality this reality is
not coming externally at you this
Consciousness is unfolding from within
you in the moment where else could it be
where else could it be but potentially
Limitless Alternatives potentially
unbridled possibility
and for you you think you could have
become the man that sat in front of me
now with via a different pathway
yeah but but or you know also no you
know like because like I'm what I
suppose I'm saying is I accept this the
the path that I've walked and that you
know that I'm sort of continuing to walk
and I suppose anyone that's in the
engaged in the process of recovery has
to as a part of that accept the various
chapters episodes
that that have led to that I mean I
think that's part of self-acceptance
part of self-acceptance is to appreciate
and understand
the various steps that have led you to
where you are and just again I think to
reiterate that that that's why I
mentioned addiction and Recovery early
on because it provides you with I access
to an archetype but this is who I was
these were this is the way that I lived
this is the way that I try to handle the
challenges that life gives you
impermanence temporality death
inequality hypocrisy destruction all of
these things that sort of are pervasive
whether that's cultural or simply part
of being in an A-10 in a temporal and
spatial reality
recovery gives you a different set of
tools a different a different way to
deal with those same challenges which
for one of a better word I will call
spiritual a spiritual solution to what I
regard now as a spiritual problem okay
once again tagging that idea of
connection that you've helped us set up
this conversation using spirituality as
a as a as a as a form of connection
um
you know when a lot of people are put
off by the term spirituality because it
sounds a little bit exclusive and a
little bit but the the you know I've
would class myself now as being
spiritual that thanks in part I have to
say to my my partner who is a breath
work instructor and I met in you know in
Bali and so on but one of the quotes
that I love from you is like many
desperate people I need spirituality I
need God or I cannot COPE in this world
I need to believe in the best in people
since I've become spiritual I have found
that it's easier to be alive
spiritual what is what is that word
spiritual literally means not Material
that's what it means it's not observable
or measurable the problem perhaps that
we have nowadays is that we live in a
quantitative reality where all things
are measurable where all things are base
predicated on rational principles but
all of us know what love is all of us
know what intuition is
all of us know as C.S Lewis beautifully
outlines in Mere Christianity when we
have transgressed against some moral
code that appears to have been instilled
in us and in spite of the advocacy and
campaigning of evolutionary biologists
seems to appeal to some newmanistic
tendency numenistic meaning simply a
sense of or a sense of Oneness a sense
of Glory a sense of Glory you might
experience at Sunrise or sunset or
looking into the eyes of a loved one or
even a stranger and knowing that the
connection is real knowing that the
unitive force is real and that somehow
this connection implies a set of Ethics
morals and principles it's not just oh
wow God is one Let's Lose ourselves in
some hedonistic revelry
that pleasure is not an end point that
service is our way of acknowledging this
Unity
so spirituality for me is a survival
technique you won't get very far in this
world without it and if you don't have
it in a declared explicit and I don't
mean doctrinal way I mean personal but
somehow connected and communal way
you will try to create God you will try
to create a spirituality from your
preferences your preferences will become
your God I prefer it when people talk to
me like this I repel this my aversions
and my preferences will become my
religion and this is I'm capable of that
today if I had that I'm lucky to be such
a craving mad smack it and it's nice to
walk around the streets of shoreditch
where I have used where I've scored
where I know the back streets of Brick
Lane where there are enclaves where they
serve up Muslim men wearing full regalia
that would never deal with that kind of
business it's against the Quran but
serve it up to slip down them rat runs
to see it Trace across the silver page
to lose myself in smack world and to
come back here now with a a different
way a different way the city has changed
and I've changed and no man crosses the
same river twice and no Man visits the
same shoreditch twice because the man is
different and sure that she's different
are we looking for the same thing then I
was looking for the same thing then like
when I was looking around Ben for smack
and crack and all of that I was looking
for the things that I'm looking for now
and if I'm not very rigorous in my
spiritual practices and they're still
sort of simple I know I can use a lot of
long words it's a thing I like doing I
get off on it and stuff but spirituality
ain't complicated my Nan's better at it
than I am my mum my wife they're all
better at it than I may do it natural
because they're not like mobilized by
this sort of primer primordial yearning
that can become my fuel it ain't no easy
task to turn all that gunge that swamp
gunge that Neolithic jet fuel into love
of one another there's been there's
people now that are living a life where
including me probably too many many
respects that are using preference as
our God yes you sniff that strangely
well because I thought is there chlorine
in it really I just wondered what is it
water water okay I don't think that's
chlorine I hope there's no chlorine
those people that are choosing
preference as their God now that are
living a life maybe where materialism is
there is their their savior
um what is there's a couple of questions
I have here you know that the Russell
that was in shortage for other reasons
Once Upon a Time and the Russell that's
in shortage now
you said that they were both looking for
the same thing
what was old Russell finding and why
wasn't the thing he found as good as the
thing he finds now I.E what is the
outcome of those that are choosing
preference as their God
like why is that such a bad thing what
is the what is the long-term or
short-term consequence well I wouldn't
suggest that there is but one path uh as
they say as Krishna Murray says truth is
a pathless land we've got to find it
ourselves but that said there are
templates paradigms conditions and
practices that might help us so I'm not
making a judgment on anyone else's path
my spirituality is not about you should
be doing this and you should be doing
that my spirituality is I should be
doing this I should be doing that my
morality is about my conduct if someone
else wants me to judge them or help them
or guide them or Aid them and I'm able
to then it is my duty to do it
but what I would say is is if you are
using impermanent means to achieve a
permanent solution you can only fail if
you are mistaking the vehicle for the
self for the essence of the self you can
only fail if you have not interrogated
who is this in here what is this
subjective experience that only I am
having how do I deal with the tension of
the Paradox and remember all energy
comes from polarity all energy comes
from polarity that I am infinitesimally
small to the point of being absolutely
Irrelevant in a cosmic Framing and yet
all reality takes place solely as far as
I know within my Consciousness quick one
before we get back to this episode just
give me 30 seconds of your time
two things I wanted to say the first
thing is a huge thank you for listening
and tuning into the show week after week
means the world to all of us and this
really is a dream that we absolutely
never had and couldn't have imagined
getting to this place
secondly it's a dream where we feel like
we're only just getting started and if
you enjoy what we do here please join
the 24 of people who watch this channel
regularly and have hit the Subscribe
button means more than I can say and if
you hit that subscribe button here's a
promise I'm going to make to you I'm
gonna do everything in my power to make
this show as good as I can now and into
the future we're going to deliver the
guests that you want me to speak to and
we're going to continue to keep doing
all of the things you love about the
show
thank you thank you so much back to the
episode one of the things I've thought a
lot about recently you mentioned a God
in your belly or that person or that
signal in your belly that's that's
trying to tell you how you feel and
we've all become so phenomenally good at
tuning out of that and tuning into the
kind of external how how you feel like
how you should feel based on the job or
title status that you have and this is a
stronger noise and Signal now than this
one
um your life has been this you talked
about mentors as well your life has been
this
amazing
Journey from chapter to chapter to
chapter as this person described as
Transcendence
the question I'm getting at is like I'm
thinking about someone right now that
sat in the city
and they know they feel like [__] at a
deeper level but they've gotten so good
to listening to their mother's opinion
of them becoming a stockbroker
that it's almost hard to hear that
feeling of I feel like [__] how do we go
on the Journey of changing how do we get
there
well typically Stephen the Journey
Begins With A departure from home
interestingly whatever home is you have
to leave you have to leave the familiar
the place that you are familiar with
scary
often this is induced by crisis a crisis
that you cannot avoid or delay or defer
a crisis of some kind may come of course
this can be an inner crisis a moment of
Despair often a psychic breakdown can
be can precipitate change transition
Awakening
I suppose
what you have to earn what one way that
you can do it this is the way that I
would do it the way that I have done it
is firstly to acknowledge the problem of
my condition to admit there is a problem
and that my life has become unmanageable
these are not my ideas what are the
signals of that
unhappiness sadness like in a sense
that's like that one one thing that's
good about that is you're trusting your
personal Integrity it's not like oh
you're Delirious why are you not happy
why is this not working for you
problem on manageability you're sad I'm
using in fact the example you use
someone in a city hold up left with the
familial and cultural conditioning that
has left them at odds maladjusted to a
maladjusted world
one there's a problem life is
unmanageable too you've got to believe
it's possible to change if you don't
believe it's possible to change you will
never be able to Marshal your inner
resources towards making that change one
way that this change can be made is
through mentorship even if that
mentorship is in the abstract even if
you've just chosen hey this person seems
to be able to have done that he says
that he used to feel weak inferior
incompetent uh impotent and he says now
that he doesn't feel those feelings so
maybe if I do what they did maybe I can
change also so this so this
and the third component first one
acknowledgment of powerlessness second
one belief change is possible third
principle it will not come from the same
map and rubric that you've been running
on up till now you're gonna have to
import new ideas you will need help that
help I would offer you might be of a
divine nature prayer meditation humility
to ask for something greater than your
my individual want my individual
preference is not just some wish list
passed up to the cosmic Center it is and
it is a
acknowledgment that there is a
requirement for growth and indeed that
I'm no longer prescribing what outcomes
I want It's Curious there are often
paradoxes in this so for me mate it's
like first you admit the powers that the
powerlessness and the nature of the
problem second I believe it's possible
to change and I base that one hang on a
minute these people used to have that
problem and they've changed so what if I
do what they did then maybe my life will
change these are all things derived from
12-step ideology the third thing is
accept someone else's plan accept
someone else's help it's surrender
because in the s in the end this is the
think perhaps the hardest contradiction
at least I find it a very hard
contradiction to live with this idea of
activated surrender and a return to the
original condition activate it surrender
Russell is no longer in charge Russell
is no longer in charge Russell is a
servant there is a master I am in the
service of this now in I recognize those
words are pretty loaded but I'm saying
that this is if you you can envisage a
benign and loving mother or father
rather than Authority and if you do
consider authority to be mostly malign I
could not identify more strongly my
distrust and my dislike of authority is
a deep deep fuel in me I do not like
being told what to do I do not like it
it is a big big part of my religion I
have to stop myself reflexively doing
the opposite of what I'm told if someone
speaks to me authoritatively someone
asked me to help them I will do my level
best to help them if someone tells me
what to do I find it very very difficult
indeed not to do the opposite Anarchist
calisthenics break rules every day just
to remind yourself that you belong to
something higher than a set of systems
potentially imposed by a malevolent
Force
step three there's you reference the
first time
um was about running basically a new
instruction manual for your life like
accepting a because the current
instruction manual is clearly not
producing the results you seek so a new
instruction manual for your life and um
my brain went but how do I know which
one to pick because there's many
Temptations For It For A New Path
forward you know there's the I could
join a cult in Arizona or I could I
could I might see seek meaning and
surrender and all the in another wrong
place from my preferences to something
even more destructive or
um how do we know you know how do we
know what what new instruction manual to
run our lives on when we find ourselves
in such a situation I'm thinking again
about that person who finds himself in a
job because their parents have told them
to go and get that job and now or they
they're working any job or they feel
like something is wrong
they admit it step one
step two is they seek out mentors to
provide evidence that it's possible to
leave the situation
and then step three is this idea of
surrendering and running your life on a
new instruction manual
where do I find that instruction manual
is it from my mentors it's interesting
isn't it yes possibly yes quite quite
likely yeah because I feel we're in a
crisis of authority most people don't
trust the government most people don't
trust the media many people don't trust
the Judiciary or state Authority and I
would have to confess that I am inclined
to agree that we are in a true crisis of
authority who indeed would you trust to
say I will do what is right I will do
what is right for you I'll do what is
right for the community and trust that
they are speaking on behalf of a set of
principles that would could be somehow
Universal and truly valid
how I have handled this is I've been
fortunate enough through crisis and
despair to find myself primarily
connected to a group of other people the
same as me who cannot cope with reality
unless they drink or use drugs and those
people provide me with a paradigm for
moving forward and a program and I like
that word program because it's both a
sort of very old-fashioned word but also
a Ultra Modern word in terms of you know
software for example okay thanks mate
yeah
and
and I guess at some point we're going to
have to trust ourselves but when
embarking on this journey it's not easy
to lean into into intuition and it isn't
easy to trust others I find trust very
very difficult I don't know about you
mate I don't know what kind of
experiences you've had there as a young
man in Plymouth but for me trust ain't
my go-to that's not my go-to it takes me
a little while my strategy is do not re
put yourself in a situation where you
require trust why because maybe people
are going to let you down bad maybe
maybe the the systems will follow you be
they educational legal judicial maybe
they're going to let you down maybe they
can't rely down I mean I was kicked out
of school but for you know I was
expelled from school I went to
University for one day left that oh yeah
I do all these things I remember it I
recognize it in your story but that that
I don't have the same level of
I'm skeptical I require evidence to
accept things I'm kind of subjective or
you know evidence that I but I'm not I
wouldn't say I'm distrusting
broadly
oh well maybe I am to some degree
is that yeah it's a critique it's an
analytic it's a perspective of until you
no but your problem with your your
challenges with authority that are
Clearing Your Story through school and
institutions all these things where does
that come from in you
that that what is and how would you
describe it well now I would describe it
as a very deep love of God and a great
deal of respect for other people's
individual liberty and freedom and the
idea that any Central Authority would
impose that without clear consent
achieved through democracy and Community
a community dialogue seems ridiculous to
me
but obviously it's biographical and
interpersonal that the circumstances of
my life have shown me that the people
one way or another that are in positions
of authority on the various scales of
authority that most people encounter
familial social educational have not
been able to fulfill their duties
required of them of course as a person
that's a certain way down the path now
because in the words of Philip Larkin
they in their turn were [__] up too
that we are just part of a long lineage
of people coping with broken broken
systems and I would say from agriculture
onwards systems of aggregation
centralization accumulation that can't
enshrine the rights of the individual
except for a certain set of individuals
that we are living in a system that's
about centralizing or centralizing power
and increasing Authority diminishing
individual Freedom using whatever
rhetorical tricks are required safety
can be convenience whatever is required
to achieve this centralized Authority
now so I now feel like you said before
how there are other ways that you could
have ended up being this man in this
chair now I am glad that I have been
deeply schooled in mistrust of authority
that it's almost like it burns in me I
can tell watch them watch what they're
telling you watch what they're telling
you I give it to my own children and I
hope I'm not doing them a disservice
question authority question it question
it and of course this makes bedtime
difficult because who's the person
telling them bedtime but it makes
schooling because institutions have an
inertia institutions have a tendency
they might start off with we're going to
educate these kids to be creative and
individuals but in the end it's going to
be about health and safety in the end
it's gonna be about fire drills in the
end it's going to be a set of a a
bureaucratic enmeshment and Maze that
prevents individual Freedom the great
David Graver God Rest his solo he was a
communist so he maybe wouldn't thank me
for saying that David Graber says that
out one of our great uh dialectics
against Soviet communism for example was
that they were bureaucracies that
prohibited individual freedom but look
at the bureaucracies we live within now
how do they solve the problem of spying
and stealing your data just make someone
tap I agree don't stop spying continue
to spy continue to accumulate the data
just tap agree you agreed to be spied on
this is bureaucracy this is these are
the observable tendrils and symptoms of
a centralized Authority that is not
necessarily sent a sentient occultist or
overtly corrupt but a tendency to
accumulate power to dominate resources
that is plainly observable in the
geopolitical dramas that play out in our
time the ecological crises and the
evident mainstream main stage players
that occupy our current time that many
of whom have not been elected to get
there I'm talking about unelected
acronym organizations that have a great
deal of influence in the world today so
the reason I don't trust is not you know
I love my mum and dad Ron brand Babs
brand in fact like today sat here in
shoreditch as an adult man I wouldn't
just walk around Essex and go to find
some couple of working-class kids and
say why don't you and you take
responsibility for my Spiritual
Development they did their very best
they could and I couldn't love them more
I couldn't Evermore but my mom she had
cancer like eight times in a few years
my dad he's got his own deal he's got
his own deal and I recognize what it is
to feel strong individualistic further I
love them I love them
when I'm trying to formulate and I know
I'll make errors as a parent of course I
will we all do and as you will Discover
it is our duty to wound our children
it's not our duty it is a necessity
beyond the duty it is a tendency it's
just gonna they're gonna end up wounded
they have to they're gonna have to find
a second mother a second father they're
gonna have to they're gonna have to
so
it's not anybody's fault it's not even
the system's fault I'm kind of grateful
to all of it now I'm grateful to these
institutions I'm grateful to the
mainstream media I'm grateful to these
governments I'm grateful that they have
set out the instruments required for the
change that we will encounter in the
coming few decades you you mentioned
your mum and your father again there um
your father what role
what impact was did his departure have
do you think on hindsight on your
relationship with authority if any at
all I would say fatherless men like I
don't want to be so solipsistic as to
make this entirely about me he says 20
years into a career
but I think for and I've experience with
fatherless men who I deal with a lot in
my uh what I would say my spiritual life
is to be around men a lot that are in
recovery both being mental bi and
mentoring and recovering mutually in
support communities
broadly fatherless men feel a big burden
and they do not feel safe in this world
a big burden not safe in this world if
they're with the mother I think they
feel it is their duty to look after the
mother if they are without other parents
I mean you know if without I have a
parent my God who knows what kind of
chaos and I'm not saying there is only
one way and that there is only template
but one template but I'm because I'm
already talking about a subset I'm
talking about a subset of people that
have become drug addicts and alcoholics
in order to deal with these kind of
challenges but also I know people that
don't identify as addicts in exactly
that way and still the absence of the
father and that also by the way you know
could be through therefore it could be
could break up with a relationship or it
could be because the father doesn't have
the emotional lexicon to connect yeah
one way or another because I can think
of examples top of my head of all of
those
I think it feels that you are
prematurely invited to be a man in fact
when I was thinking about our interview
Stephen because you'll be glad to know I
thought about you before
I felt the significance of anthropology
the significance of what the original
condition might be I do not use these
terms to suggest there is some one
template that could be imposed and
stamped upon everyone I would never take
away people's individual strike rights
or struggles particularly those
connected to obvious and evident civil
rights cultural and identity issues
those are their stories for them and I
support them in those stories
but when it comes to how human beings
might have lived for hundreds of
thousands of years it appears we do well
when we are a connected unit that
communicate together in order to achieve
a common goal
time and time again when anthropologists
and even uh contemporary psychologists
study these forms of society they
discover that there are rights of
initiation for both males and females
although they're often appears based on
what I have heard and as you know I'm
not an expert to be particular emphasis
on male initiation as the body is not so
uniform in the way that it informs a boy
that it is a grown-up now not a child
anymore and that there are new duties to
be undertaken one of the best examples I
ever heard and I feel I see somewhere in
Freud or maybe in Joseph Campbell
is that I feel this is some Australian
Aboriginal tribe that they what they do
and I think they're doing this now I
figure I don't know you know I'm putting
this stuff together you know how it goes
that the boys at a certain age are
dragged away from the mother and they
make much of it they wear masks the men
of the village all the men apart father
all the women are part mother and of
course there are categories for other
forms of identity too which they honor
and Revere often in the form of the
shaman who is beyond gender identity
incorporating both you see reflections
of this to this day even in monotheistic
faiths where the priest wears what
appears to be neutral or androgynous
attire distinguishing them from the rest
of the community yet honoring them and
revering them
and you went through that
um initiation way too early
in your own words you say that you were
prematurely forced to be a man because
you've got the duties of care over your
over your mother
at a young young age your father leaves
I think six six months old and then the
other thing that happens which feels
like a horrible turn in
turn you know horrible sense of chances
your mother has cancer
um and she struggles with it for many
many years so you've got this young boy
and I was thinking about this when I was
doing the research for this conversation
you've got this very young young boy
who's struggling with a lot of things on
his own disconnection coming from all
angles and then the stability in his
life become
gets the the uncertain
um
horror of cancer come into her life
and what that does to that young boy
who's already destabilized in sense of
like connection these are all
interpretations I have from reading a
piece of paper you know if I'm just
being honestly I just I was putting
myself in those shoes and saying I've
got this stable figure here in my life
my mother and I'm dealing with all this
instability over here and then this
becomes unstable yeah it's good analysis
but you know really my mother struggles
them as her struggles she had to go
through that and bravely she's done it
what life force that woman has in her
and to pick up on a point within your
question you cannot fake being a man or
a woman or an adult let's say a word
that doesn't have any cultural load to
Bear you can't fake that or you can fake
it and I did fake it and that is what
people do they fake it they fake it but
in a sense maybe it you need another
adult to make you that you need to be
initiated you need a code you need to
know that it's about Duty and
responsibility that it's not all just
about Swagger and Personal Achievement
and like many young men I joined the
group of Lost Boys I found men young
young men kids kids because if I met
them now that's what they were as kids a
couple of years older than me that that
becomes your tribe unless you have
hierarchies and systems of acculturation
and inculcation that are based on higher
values remember our earlier point about
moral Authority and Trust who you're
going to give it over to You'll create
your own one you'll create your own
little Community we're without Elders
without Elders that are reliable and
trustworthy and dutiful and understand
the nature of sacrifice sacrifice of
themselves in order to perform them
duties so of course yes I feel like when
you feel the incumbency of adulthood
upon you early due to the conditions of
your domestic trial there you will have
to as they say man up or woman up you
will have to but it won't be real
because it can't be real because it's
not only a set of endocrineal
imperatives it's also a system of
instruction as laid out in that as laid
out in the previous anecdotes the
cambellian analysis of the
anthropological conditions of that
Aboriginal group there so really until
you find other adults Elders that are
like I'm I know what I'm doing you don't
need to worry I'm stronger than you it's
going to be okay I'll look after you
it's all right do this that of you know
a father a father like a father is you
know you're gonna forego this now
because in the future this you know
without that you will not forgo you will
consume now you will consume now you
will not understand you will not
understand your role
Bears repeating you know without shall
worship no other gods than me because
otherwise you will worship them Gods you
will worship pleasure money Fame them
gods are greedy little Gods too they're
easy little deities to start worshiping
and the problem with the worship of
those Gods is you lose the principle of
the Divine the interconnectivity the
pleasure is not the result pleasure is a
byproduct pleasure is an inadvertent
byproduct please God of doing the right
thing I was just thinking then as you're
talking about
um
all of that and the gods we choose to to
worship and young men and fatherlessness
I was thinking about the Andrew Tate
phenomenon
as a form of he really seems to have
captured a huge amount of young men for
some reason and trying to diagnose why
why that is is a very multifaceted
um process isn't it because there's
elements of purpose and meaning and um
having a figure in your life that you
can can guide you can initiate you into
what being a man is that it seems that
young men are in search of yes I agree I
agree I agree no doubt one of the
challenges it feels like we have
culturally Stephen is we are unable to
observe the difference between symptom
and cause yeah symptom and cause and
obviously as with matters medical cause
is what we must analyze cause is what we
must understand there's no point saying
you shouldn't do this you shouldn't do
that if you have a set of values that
are pretty simple I call them Sesame
Street values kindness love service
that's gonna take care of care of a hell
of a lot if you have kindness love
service it's going to take care of a
hell of a lot are you being kind right
now no you've gone off track mate you've
gone off track you're not being kind are
you being off service no
then we can maybe sift through different
also with we live in a such a curated
space that it's difficult to discern
what people are actually angry about
sometimes what is it as one of my great
teachers says to me what is it don't get
caught up in the phenomena the Epi
phenomena the distractions the static
what is it that you are trying to
understand what is it you're trying to
do
all of these groups then people that are
big fans of and Andrew take people that
are radically left people that are
radically right
what is it that they that they are that
they are they are seeking or that they
are getting from from such a radical
Pursuit well a argument might be that we
are recognizing that there is nothing in
our Evolution to suggest that we live in
cultures of 300 million people who live
by one ideology that we have to truly
respect diversity that we have to
acknowledge that many of our most
influential and Powerful systems
do not have our best intentions in mind
that they in fact benefit from ongoing
cultural conflagration if we can do one
great service in this cultural space I
recognize that part of your goal and
your mission is to awaken latent potency
in individuals in honor of your own
journey and it is a great Mission if I
may say but part of this Mission must be
for us to learn this simple lesson we
have more in common with one another
than that than divides us and it is our
duty to reach out in particular to the
people we disagree with in a spirit of
love and good faith firstly then
identify oh am I reaching out in good
faith to people I already agree with no
no no no no no that's not it this agree
with I disagree with that on this
important hot button topic of guns or
pro-life pro-choice or Identity or
tradition or progression I disagree with
them and I respect you're right I
respect and I love you and I know that I
do not know what you know that I am not
God I am not God I do not know I do not
have any authority over you but I
believe that together we can achieve a
consensus and this consensus must be
founded on good faith we must allow one
another to communicate in good grace and
openness we cannot yield to censorship
not because we want people to feel the
air with toxicity and hate but because
we know that if we try to control it who
has the right who are we granting the
right to now have you investigated any
of these organizations have you
investigated their funded their
affiliations their agenda their
imperative because to some degree I am
sorry to report that I have and I have
found them wanting they will not be
getting my consensus for Authority
anytime soon and I would offer you this
you have more in common with the people
you are fighting with those you most
loathe whatever Hue persuasion or a
cultural garment you've conveniently
strewn upon him then the people that are
saying that they will protect you the
institutions that are saying they will
protect you are you optimistic yes God
is real
you're optimistic that we'll get to a
place where we recognize that our
similarities are greater than our
differences yes and so if I make Russell
Brand I know I don't think this is a
role you want but if I make you prime
minister or president of the world
how how do you systemically change
things to help us achieve the objectives
you've described in connection Community
kindness and togetherness what are the
things I've asked so many people this
question no one's ever wanted to answer
it
bring power as close as possible to the
people affected by it default to
decentralization and localization
wherever possible of course this will
not immediately yield Perfection but
have you looked out of your window we
are not competing with perfection we are
competing with corruption so what do we
want most of all we want true democracy
all the values that people espouse are
the values we should be practicing they
say the world does not need more people
to believe in God just for those of us
that do to start acting like it to start
acting like you believe God is real
re-distribute the control of Municipal
facilities to those that are affected by
them do not have water companies in the
United Kingdom like Thames water owned
elsewhere in China or Canada or Kuwait
or Qatar or wherever those facilities
are held have Municipal facilities run
by the community that is affected by
them I'm not talking about
re-nationalization I'm talking about
Community the community runs its water
wherever possible I recognize that there
is some complexity when it comes to
electricity municipality running roads
running hospitals but who Among Us has
ever been into a hospital and not
marveled at the beauty The Compassion
the Ingenuity the commitment the
devotion of the people that work there
wouldn't it be better if the people that
clean the floors in the hospital felt
that they were invested in it that it
was their Hospital the nurses that
worked there the doctors that they have
real power that those are their
hospitals wouldn't it be better if both
sides of our political conversation I'm
talking about the United Kingdom right
now hadn't agreed already that
privatization is the way to go and
they're not going to do anything about
it I'm not saying that there's anything
wrong with capitalism in its uh basic
format of we create a product and the
people want the product and look at that
we made a little bit of money I'm
talking about this gigantic
metastasized monster devouring
everything right down to Spirit we must
recognize where centralized Authority is
coalescing most and this we must address
this we must address whether it is
financial corporate or state power
wherever it is possible we the people we
the people those three magical
constitutional words if they were
listened to if they were lived by it's
already there the Kingdom of Heaven is
spread upon the Earth and man sees it
not it's already here it comes from
inside your Consciousness you awaken you
believe it's possible to change you act
like it's going to happen that's how
these things unfold it's happened again
and again the Miracles of transition and
change the great beauty of science and
medicine and Technology when it is freed
from its tendrils when it is untethered
from the mendacious objectives of a
system that sees all things as Dominion
for materialization and commodity when
it is freed from that you will see the
true genius of our scientists the true
genius capable in technology if we can
just address the model if we can just
have as an agenda an awareness that we
are just on one Little Rock in Infinite
Space right now that we're all
participating in this one centralized
idea and yet infinite diversity infinite
individual Freedom infinite ways of
Being Human we must all take
responsibility for becoming the person
we're intended to be and if you don't
know who that is you find someone who
does and you find a system in a program
that can help you and we'll all do our
best together and it's going to be
glorious glorious about Beyond glorious
it is necessary one of the things you
said within there was about empowering
nurses for example in cleaners cleaners
in a hospital and it reminded me of a
study I read many years ago that showed
nurses that were given ownership about
the decisions within a hospital had
um higher satisfaction there was less
accidents there was less um accidents
with with misprescribed medications
there was um higher retention and when
they they leveled out that the payment
um the remuneration policy so there was
less unfairness in how people
remunerated all the standards of the
hospital went through the roof because
people were empowered they had autonomy
and control over their lives and work so
I completely relate to that my question
though is about step one because it what
you described there sounds like it's at
the top of Everest and sometimes when
something feels it does for even for me
it feels like it's a long way away from
where we are now so I'm asking what's
the first Pebble what's the first Domino
that has to fall what's the first thing
that I can do as an individual to help
us get closer to that world
well firstly Stephen people climb
Everest every single day yeah they have
to clear the litter from that mountain
in now
once it was considered inconceivable and
every time there is an epocal shift
every time we say oh it seems that the
sun doesn't go around the earth it seems
like the earth goes around the Sun oh
there are things that are smaller than
atoms it appears that these sub
particular phenomena that are so small
is even difficult to label them exist in
a unified field that they are emanating
but somehow connected to I'm speaking of
course of quantum entanglement if you
reverse the charge of a particle
thousands of miles away the partnering
the partnering particle will reverse its
charge also there appears to be some
unitive Force
what I'm expressing is the most simple
practical effortless achievement that we
will ever yet undertake it is merely the
realization of the truth that we are
individual yes but we are connected also
that there are
goliaths that have incrementally
coalesced due to the progression of the
great sometimes unacknowledged
revolutions I'm not saying loans
acknowledge agriculture Industrial
Revolution technological Revolution that
all of these have been undergirded by
principles of dominion that might as
well be feudalism in a sense there is no
change at all except for the individual
change that you yourself can make this
is why I think people get a lot of
traction when they say you know look
after yourself this is part of it eat
well awaken pray meditate recognize that
it is normal to feel sometimes total
Despair and total despondency remember
all of these great Journeys that we're
describing that you're fascinated we've
began with exactly that exactly that
that the great sages and secular saints
that we have been granted have shown us
and told us be the change that you want
to see in the world whether it's our
Gandhi or our Malcolm X people that are
willing to give their life for what they
believe in because what they believe in
is bigger than their life and you're
gonna die anyway you're gonna die anyway
but your principles this is eternity
that we can touch eternity in the moment
so it's not like woo-woo to say meditate
wake up this is changing the Prima
Materia it is the field of Consciousness
this is I suppose what I'm advancing
Consciousness precedes matter you have
unique individual access to
Consciousness you are online you are on
the grid you are responsible for whether
or not you believe this is possible
nobody else can tell you what to do
there that is your private Kingdom your
private domain where you can be for now
for now whoever you want to be in there
please do not relinquish that right by
not taking it now for I tell you
authoritarian forces are abundant and
abound they are looking to colonize the
very space of attention that exists
right now this moment this is what is
being colonized attention data data on
what you
the territory of the self this is
fertile this is not nothing it is not
nothing to awaken to the reality of who
you are in this very moment that is not
nothing Stephen
quick one as you know Airbnb are a
sponsor of this podcast and I was
actually in an Airbnb last weekend when
me and my friends had a reunion in New
York and it's from staying in airbnbs
over the years that led me to start
hosting my own place I know friends of
mine who actually Airbnb their own place
in order to pay for the Airbnb they use
when they're away on holiday which is
pretty smart and maybe you stayed in an
Airbnb before and thought this is
actually pretty doable maybe my place
could be an Airbnb it could be as simple
as starting with a spare room or your
entire place you could be sitting on an
Airbnb and not even know it whether you
could use some extra money to cover your
bills or something a little bit more fun
your home might be worth more than you
think and you can find out how much it's
worth at Airbnb dot code UK slash host
check it out find out how much your home
is worth and let me know what you think
one of my team members had a question
for you I was just chatting to them
about about you and they said you know I
really want to know how he lives on a
day-to-day basis because I know from
your books and stuff the Russell that
roam the streets of shoreditch Once Upon
a Time
the Russell I see now is through the
lens of YouTube and I see him what it
looks like the countryside somewhere
he'd like some logs in the back
what is your what how do you live your
life now I'm glad you've asked this
because this is proper Diary of a CEO
stuff because this is actual scheduling
I have to live sort of like a monk
basically I have to be conscious all the
time I have to be conscious about what I
eat otherwise I'll eat something stupid
I have to be conscious about what I say
otherwise I'll say something stupid I
have to be conscious about what I do I
have to familiarize myself with extremes
continually so I thank you God have uh
access to hot temperatures and cold
temperatures I expose myself to them
regularly every day if possible do a lot
of cold therapy I get right in that cold
and while I'm in that cold I think this
thing taught to me by Michael Singer and
anyone who's willing to watch Michael
Singer stuff the moment in front of you
is not bothering you you are bothering
yourself about the moment in front of
you they're now getting very very hot
temperatures and I think the same thing
the moment in front of you is not
bothering you you're bothering yourself
at the moment in front of you I do
Brazilian Jujitsu because for me it was
not natural to tangle like that and I
love Brazilian Jiu Jitsu so much cause a
Rogan actually was the first person I've
ever talk about all that stuff and I do
that a couple of times a week I do why
I think people to touch one another in a
way that is playful and absolutely
consensual but sort of assertive it's
like kind of I heard a YouTuber say like
dance actually and it's very good for me
it really puts me in my body it's not
cerebral I don't know about you Stephen
but I suspect you're the same I am very
uh intellectually oriented I live in
here I'm if I find it very easy to be
self-obsessed and to get caught up in
all that stuff so things that put me in
my body the body the body holds the key
the body the body you've got a body is
important the body of Christ it's very
important to get in that cold water it's
very important to get into that yoga
very important these things are
important and beautiful and connecting
so I do a lot of BJJ I do a lot of yoga
I do a lot of other type of exercises
calisthenics body weight type stuff to
try and stay fit I got you know I got
young children I have another child
coming I have to stay fit I have to be
able to be God willing present for these
children going forward and I love it and
it's what we're going to do we're
animals again this anthropological idea
how might we have lived for those
hundreds of thousands of years that
pre-date the great miracle of
Agriculture how might we have lived
we've worked We Touch one another we are
socializing we groom and we graze
together it's nice like the kind of
trust you develop up with people in
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu like that they'll
choke you and what to the point of
unconsciousness but then when you tap
it's over and this is something that you
share between you is there's a trust in
that as well isn't it
yes trust good to embody the trust that
experience the trust as they say if you
want to know if you can trust someone
trust someone and maybe it's difficult
to seek out those kind of opportunities
where it can play out you know so
microcosmically and practically because
I I did a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu lesson or
two and that man could have killed me at
any moment I really knew he could have
killed me he had me like tied up like a
I don't know like a like a ball of
elastic bands and I knew at any moment
he could kill me but I trusted him and I
didn't know this man it's lovely isn't
it there's something amazing about it
and it's an instant bonding that this
man has his life in my hands yet he's
he's teaching me an art form he's
teaching me a discipline
um and holding my literally my life In
His Hands
um it's funny because I didn't know him
but I felt like he was my mentor my
father my
immediately after yeah because I trusted
him with so much my life right so
absolutely wonderful thing touch very
important for us late ape creatures
that's why a hairdressers you tell the
hairdresser or the barber stuff this is
why like and Strictly Come Dancing they
can't stop falling in love they're
performing these rituals that are
designed to elicit a certain States the
vulnerability isn't it that's the
connection the vulnerability the touch
the awareness of sameness but
differentness the acknowledgment that we
are creatures that we are embodied
creatures all of these things I think
contribute to that so for me on my day
yes every day prayer and meditation
first thing every day rigorously ensure
that I have done things for other people
preferably without letting other people
find out that I make myself available to
other in my case in particular men that
require help with their issues around
addiction and mental health that I have
checked in with other people that I
consider to be peers around the
challenges that I face psychology
magically that I don't spend all my time
Obsession just about what I want like
that I have to do quite a lot to not be
crazy I have to do quite a lot to not be
crazy so the hot the cold the BJJ the
yoga uh there's someone I work with Once
who said every day I get up I meditate I
pray I do exercise I do green juice I do
hot cold I attend a support group and
then I feel okay okay that's what I get
to feel if I do all that then I don't
feel like a lunatic a vacillating wild
glass of mad vicissitudes that could
lash around anything in its search for
connection is there not another way
at this point this also is attached to
another question I've often pondered
from doing what I do here which is about
how I mean just says Steve Peters who's
a psychiatrist I believe talks about
these goblins and Gremlins and I spoke
to gabo mate as well I know you've
interviewed him and I watched that
fantastic unbelievable guy but I wonder
if the the traumas the things that are
hard I use the word hardwired
tentatively but the things that are
hardwired into us are ever overcomeable
if they if we can ever take them to zero
in terms of the power they have over us
or influence we have over all we will
spend our lives managing I was taught
from the wound comes the Salve from the
wound comes the South the place of the
deepest wounding will provide your
salvation this is what you must
investigate it is not
when people love you we always feel it's
because of their strength or the
capacity or the virtuosity but often it
is the vulnerability and the fragility
because we all know that this
vulnerability and fragility is something
we share this is what comedy is to me
Stephen is the ongoing acknowledgment
everyone's running some game I'm this
I'm doing this I've got this going on
you're gonna die
it's all gonna fall apart it's all going
to fall apart except for these permanent
principles and a connection to the
Eternal achievable through Consciousness
this is why I need Ceremony this is why
I need practice this is why I need peers
and mentors and mentees and from the
wound from this place of I'm not good
enough nobody loves me I don't fit in
the only way that I can achieve trust is
through having some uh Authority or
value as accredited by a culture that I
don't even bloody trust
as compared with a metric that I don't
even agree with instead of this now and
again continual moment to moment I'm not
suggesting that I am any better than
anybody else just that I'm not any worse
than anybody else that's the biggest
thing that I'll offer it's ongoing it's
continual but the the thing I'm glad of
it now I'm glad of the wounding and you
will be too whoever you are you will be
glad of the wounding too because it is
sadly a gift to you that doesn't mean it
was right or that there weren't
perpetrators or that it's not bad or
that the culture doesn't need to change
or any of those things all those things
are definitely true but from it you we
how all of the time you see it Go Great
Ormond Street go anywhere watch the
Paralympics it's everywhere it's
everywhere people overcome
and I asked that because so many become
frustrated that the wounding
they haven't been able to overcome it
they become frustrated by that because a
lot of the kind of I don't know maybe
Spirit reduction maybe whatever says you
can take this pill or you can do this
exercise you can do this Retreat and
then you won't be a narcissist or you
won't be a whatever right and then they
try it they buy the course then they
still are they find themselves reacting
in those old ways and being triggered in
the mechanic Machinery that you spoke of
that comes up when we're triggered it's
still there then they go [__] I need to
buy another course we do need to be very
self-compassionate and I think we have
to perhaps recognize that it is not a
commodity that can be externally
required by an external coordinate can
indeed ignite that which is already
their dormant and latent and are waiting
to be born precisely the necessity for
initiation we return to here the
initiation is to activate activate that
which is already there activated
surrender not passive surrender but not
passive surrender activated surrender
I'm a vessel I'm here for whatever you
are I trust myself God I pray to you God
not my limited conception of you God
with my tiny little mankind mind I pray
to you God as you know yourself to be
and I offer myself to you God 100 and
totally please use me please take away
from me everything that is not of use to
you put aside all my preconceptions and
use me God this this you utilizes the
wound the wound becomes a portal you
become a vessel I want to stay on how
you live so I understand your sort of
morning routine there but if I zoom out
on where you live why you choose to live
there
um your relationship with work now now
that you have this I think greater
Clarity on institutions and how you
balance that um
well like I have to make a lot of
content yeah because every day I'm on
Rumble every day I make an hour of
content every day we make an additional
10 to 15 to 20 minute video on a news
subject that generally encompasses an
establishment narratives and a way of
explaining that that is hopefully
inclusive
every day we have other social media
content we have a business like that I'm
part of a significant
business Endeavor that I regard as a
movement rather than a business but as
you are all too aware if it doesn't
function as a business it will not
function at all so it has to have good
hygiene and housekeeping you're a CEO I
literally am here not under the pretense
of being a CEO but because it is part of
my job and I do have a diary although I
don't keep it myself and I try not to
look at it but it exists and so I have
to participate continually with that and
ensure that an organization is around me
that is able to facilitate the things
that I'm good at and accommodate the
many things where I am currently looking
to improve
I have to make all the other content we
try to do this in three days that means
a couple of days a week I'm available
for different types of expedition and
Adventure such as this one
this is why for me the spiritual life it
has to come first but not not out of a
sort of an ethical evaluation
spirituality in the end is a survival
technique it's not like esoteric it's
not like I'm doing this thing like
waving around incense or dressing up in
a row I'm trying to not go crazy and end
my life and damage the life of people
around me by devoting myself they say
only the really crazy people become
Saints only the really crazy people
would even consider it you have to need
it it has to be Beyond wanting because
wanting is just here to keep the blob
going how does it feel to be in your
mind
could you describe it to me that was
amazing but sometimes it's very very
sometimes it's very very fast sometimes
it's very volatile I feel like it
undulates a lot this I understand to be
very common to add experiences of
extreme High extreme low fastness not
natural to be Serene evaluating
information very very quickly it feels
fast sometimes very fast and it has a
strong sense of craving and longing
which is a type of magnetism I suppose
and I suppose magnetism is a longing for
Unity connection it's very difficult to
discern physical forces because they are
by their nature
non-anthropological and it's very easy
to anthromorphize physical phenomena
like gravity or magnetism or whatever so
what feels like if me is that there is a
great deal to get done that's what it
feels like there is a great deal that
needs to get done and in order to do it
I have to surrender strongly otherwise I
will mess it up badly that's what it
feels like so that's there's a lot of
ceremony that is communing with that
which is unknowable you know prayer
ceremony with other people acknowledging
the sacred not forgetting the sacred
that the most important things are
difficult to measure and weigh but they
are there anyway
and so each day there is much work to be
done and I am a father of young children
and I have a dog that I adore and I have
many animals so I have a lot of very
simple uh pastoral duties that have to
be done and I have a lot of spiritual
things that have to be done to hold me
together so there's a lot to be done and
then often I get to a point where I'm so
tired that the whole Enterprise feels
like it could collapse inward like a
narcissistic semi-gothic souffle so
there has to be a lot of caution a lot
of caution also I'm a person I perhaps
you identify and agree with a sense of
purpose and Mission and a deep deep
belief that the most profound and
significant change is imaginable are
possible by virtue of the fact that they
are imaginable in fact because the role
of imagination we see all around us in
every building every object every book
every cultural artifact as well as the
many flawed and defunct aspects of our
culture also imagination is the device
that brings the unmanifest into the
Manifest this do you ever find yourself
because you are a content creator do you
ever find yourself slipping in and when
you play that game you're dealing with
algorithms and metrics and numbers and
rankings and I'm trending and I'm not
trending do you does that ever trigger
your old you know the old Machinery yeah
I try to not go near it I try to not go
because in a sense Back to Basics for me
recovery is somewhat based on abstinence
like I I don't have a odd drink or the
occasional line or the occasional or the
occasional I don't do it I don't do it
so I try to practice good hygiene there
because if I start it's very difficult
to stop and another momentum takes over
so yes it is of course it is because
these are part of the you know again
part of the blog part of the Primal ooze
competition is part of who we are status
is part of who we are so I try to stay
out of the ring as one of my teachers
says stay out of the ring stay out of
the ring what are you working on what
are you working on improving you talked
highlighted you set up your strengths
and then your things you hope to improve
what are the things that you hope to
improve
for me always patience
patience try to be patient because
impatience is ridiculous to think I know
when something should happen is mental
concept so I try to work on patience to
be very very patient
mostly I work on this there is more to
be achieved by surrendering self-will
than can ever be achieved by utilizing
it and that is a very very very very
difficult thing to practice particularly
when agitated what does that mean I I
didn't understand ah okay
we achieve so much through will I'm
going to create a podcast now look I did
that thing I was going to do now I have
to create various sets around the globe
but to believe that there is a greater
power that will come into being if I
Surrender but become intuitive to what
one of my teachers calls The Whispers on
the wind that I will be directed that I
my job is to stay out of my way that my
life is none of my business to not look
at my day like it's a chunk of thing
that I warmed my day I'm going to eat it
up this is oh wow this gift I'm alive oh
my God what a miracle is incredible and
to stay in that feeling of Grace and
stay in that feeling of gratitude and to
spot as quickly as possible when I
inevitably give it up give up your
connection to God for a biscuit give up
your connection to God because someone
has a nice car give up your connection
to God because someone says something
about you on the internet give up your
connection to God because people lie
about you or attack you don't give up
your connection to God and in order to
not give up your connection to God you
are going to have to cultivate a very
strong connection to God because
elsewhere as you say much noise much
distraction what a coincidence that we
live in an environment that seems to be
cultivated in order to distract us from
the ever-present Divine when you say God
yes are you talking about a religious
specific religious deity or are you is
there how do you define your God
loving unity and absolute respect for
individual identity within that do I
find this God in a particular book or
every book it's up to you mate
do you consider yourself to be part of a
religion
I do yeah I mean this one the only one
they're all the same I suppose if you
want some help perennialism by Aldous
Huxley is a good place to look at where
he identified in the same way that
Joseph Campbell and Carl Jung it could
be said identified respectively that
there are Mythic tropes that appear to
recur in all cultures he began to write
a a famous book which I believe gave the
name to the phrase perennialism in which
he observed the Eastern mysticism Sufism
from the world of Islam and certain
aspects of Christianity particularly
Gnostic Christianity and what is
commonly regarded as first century
Christianity had within him not
archetypes as in you know the
crucifixion which we know occurs in many
folk tales and mythologies not just in
Christianity not narrative devices or
characters that recur but ideologies
that require principles values that
occur in all of them and many of them
them or destruction is Huxley offers are
about overcome the self there is
something bigger than the self you're
not real who are you when you don't have
your name they call it the unborn in
Buddhism Marcus Aurelius says
you are dead your life is over now live
the rest of your life properly get rid
of it put down the corpse they say in
Buddhism in Christianity die that you
may be born again the flesh man must die
the carnal man of wanting and longing
must dive at the Transcendent man be
born you're getting in the way you're
getting in the way with your memories
and your story and your projects and
your values and your virtues all but the
universal ubiquitous ever-present
archetypal virtues that Huxley explains
and elsewhere through Jung and Campbell
we get the idea that there's some sort
of ulterior cultural force not cultural
Force beyond that but beyond Way Way
Beyond culture culture is what we create
indigenous Primal reality trying to ex
not trying to expressing itself through
us it's still talking to us all the time
all the time it's here it's everywhere
it's waiting to be discovered by us
collectively and individually and what
better job could we have than to find it
ourselves and help others to find it but
I think the reason why is because when
people hear the word god they think of a
man in the sky well they should stop
that unless it helps them that's that's
good if you don't behave you're going to
go to hell that's and that's an idea
that a lot of people struggle to get on
board with but that's because people
have been lazy because we are in the
Kali Yuga we are in a time of Darkness
they're forgotten in this darkness that
when people say
there is a father they mean there is a
figure that is more powerful than you
that loves you and if you don't do
what's right you are going to hell not
after you are in it if you don't do
what's right you are oh no I'm so
unhappy I'm in this bed set that we
talked about earlier why because you
didn't listen to the father because you
perhaps couldn't find the father because
as I've eluded to many times you live in
a culture that wants to distract you
from the father or the mother or
whatever word helps you that is there
within you waiting to be born that
you've been distracted from
understandably because of the Primal
urges to compete and acquire and eat and
defecay all of this is normal ordinary
forgive yourself immediately and now
move forward to what it truly means will
you understand me I understand all the
problems of religion religion shouldn't
make you hate other people religion
should make you love everyone they've
all got that written in there that why
don't we focus on that bit because if
people start doing that you can't
manipulate them moving around on a
little chessboard and turn them into
little consumer blobs obviously
obviously well where does love fit into
all of that romantic love because I
thought about some of the stuff I said
about around ancestors and is monogamy
is is monogamy the the path forward is
is romantic love a framework for
stability that we need to find God oh my
friend well there is an argument the
romantic love is derived from the idea
of chivalry which is as the word
suggests a kind of late medieval notion
that we should focus our Arda on an
individual like a knight would attach
the colors of their bequeathed betrothed
or beloved to their uh Lance as they
jousted metaphorically and really though
this chivalrous idea is but one aspect
of love and they know that many people
never had actual conjugal relationships
with the symbolic feminine divine
feminine figure that they would
attribute that quality too romantic love
I feel romantic love perhaps as all
forms of Love Obsession attachment
ultimately I was taught this I didn't
make this up uh the inappropriate
substitute for the true love of God what
is love when you whether you love West
Ham United or your wife or your children
or your beautiful before it sounds new
breath worker girlfriend except for the
desire longing yearning to be at one
with to be connected to to acknowledge
that what's in there is the same as
what's in here that we have a shared
purpose isn't love the felt awareness of
the true Unity that undergirds apparent
separation we come into form for a
little while all of us were twice twice
before we were a single cell you're a
single cell then you were two cells in
the belly of your mother and way way way
back you were an amoeba and there it is
in your programming in your coding the
unity is there materially and
practically forget esoteric theology
forget ontology it's there as a factors
and observable factors there is a cosmic
fact there was a big bang Unity is there
love is the felt remembrance of this why
does love feel good although love as we
know can be very painful when love is
not reciprocated When Love is rejected
When Love cannot unfold this love is
more than a sensation it is a duty and
it is the deepest truth of our kind that
when we love one another we acknowledge
the truth that we're not separate from
one another isn't it glorious to move
from that position where you think I
don't like that person I don't like that
person then oh my God they're the same
as me I love them I love them because
you have recognized the truth and truth
and Beauty are one as wild says that
there is something
we it rewards us it rewards us it's
speaking to us I heard it argued that
once there was a great unity and the
infinite intelligence for its own
Amusement lost in the a-temporary
spatial Abyss sent all things into
fragmentation only to see which ones
would awaken and recognize the unity of
our origin the Deep Unity of our origin
when will we come home when will we come
home to love
you fell in love then you had two
children you've got a third on the way
around the corner
that's a very special love that you've
um you've you've found
fatherhood
what is what is I'm not a father yet
but I'd love to look down the road and
get some lessons from you as a father
what lessons did fatherhood teach you
about life and how we should be living
teaches you teaches me taught me there's
a lot more important things in this
world than me but I learned this lesson
in a variety of ways now there's a lot
more important stuff in this world than
what I want and what I think and what I
reckon it don't amount to much amidst
the infinite
it taught me that love is real that the
most miraculous things are accessible
and ordinary an animal that you can
procreate life into being what a gift
and it flows through you and we're part
of an endless chain and God has no
grandchildren they belong to the world
they don't belong to you and it's your
job to just stand there and bring out of
them whatever's in them and just stand
back and Marvel and weep at what's in
them weep all right the horror the
beauty the horror the Dreadful beauty of
what a child unfolds into your awareness
that they
in the best case scenario the best case
scenario they are walking into a future
that you will not be there
to guide them through
so I suppose what that asks of you
is an understanding of your place in
this world
and acknowledgment both of
your relative insignificance but
simultaneous
omniscience omnipotence simultaneous is
a paradox all energy come from polarity
acknowledge the polarity don't hate the
polarity don't hate the others don't let
them tell you those people are different
from you because they wear a baseball
cap while they voted to leave Europe or
because they identify with these
pronouns or because they believe in this
cause or that the absolute Unity it
shows you that
the way you love your children must
become the way you level people love as
ramdas was told by his teacher tell the
truth and love Everyone not easy
not easy if you tell the truth to love
everyone
it teaches you everything it teaches you
everything to become a father it teaches
you you're going to need other fathers
it teaches you you're gonna have to
become a father it teaches you you're
gonna have to become a father to that
little boy he teaches you everything all
lessons are there
all lessons are there
a future you're not going to be a part
of
why why
it was so visible in in your
in your body and in your Consciousness
that that particular sentence was
difficult for you to say
as it relates to your children
because it's so ordinary Stephen
any old lady any old man who's chat to
anywhere
oh yeah my mum was like that my dad was
like that
my little girls
it's just so beautiful
what are the lessons about the future
that they um you
you try and give them if any at all
and are you and how do you feel about
the future that they're going to
to go into
and try my best to arm them I'm trying
my best to arm them I'm trying my best
to
arm them like Sarah Connor or something
no I'm just trying to tell them
like and also they are them there's I
see every day how they're more powerful
than me already so
you know they'll be all right God has no
grandchildren they'll be all right
they've got their path
I know they're gonna hurt me you know I
know that
I all we can do for each other Beyond
father daughter is become who you are
become who you are become who you are
become who you are trust that it's going
to be beautiful that you're not ugly
that you're not hideous you've made
mistakes you've done stuff wrong
you've had stuff done to make also all
of this all of this and yet become who
you are become who you are become who
you are so
all I want is I try to not go this is
everything I think don't go unconscious
don't go unconscious like stay present
stay present things will make you go
unconscious it might happen as I leave
this room it might happen when the
people from the next room come in I
don't you can go unconscious at any
moment don't go unconscious stay present
stay present now God is now may you find
God now that's the only place you're
going to find God you're gonna find him
yesterday you're gonna find him in a
week Godzilla Now find it find it
absolute and when I say God I mean
absolute Unity absolute inclusivity
absolute love absolute Duty among us all
so me I'm basically look you know I mean
I can't live like that with my kids can
I like bang and honor them like John
Wesley from the pulpit or MLK I just
gotta say all right how's it going do
you want that to eat I'm not letting you
eat that I'll come to why not you know I
mean I'm leaving why don't you tell me
stuff you've done at school what do you
mean you've got a boyfriend I'm doing
all I'm saying all the normal chats
everyone's happening having but what I'm
trying to do is recognize they ain't
gonna get a better conduit than me for
good enough for real so I better get the
[__] out of the way I could get out of
the way for them you know
Russell thank you so much thank you for
um thank you for being a an inspiration
to me in so many ways one of the ways
that I think I mean you you're
completely in a in a league of your own
outside of the comedy and all that is
the way that you communicate ideas in a
way that is so Brit and I know you must
be aware of this that is so brilliant
and poetic
and you said it halfway through this
conversation that it's intentional your
use of words yes you could you know you
could use simpler words yes but you
choose the poetry
but I can describe it why because why
it's not only error diet to talk like
that think of perhaps one of the great
archetypes of the working class we have
nowadays Danny Dyer yeah he's a poet he
talks beautifully it's nice to be
specific yeah if you can
be specific what do you mean what do you
mean and to be honest it's uh
inner it's always been there it's always
there
it's there
it's funny because as I was observing
you today you seem like you're just one
step ahead of the thing coming out of
your mouth and that's why you're able to
string this poetry together in such a
cohesive way in a coherent way because
your brain seems to just be one step
ahead of Mark like of the way that I
would speak yours it's wonderful to
observe and it's a wonderful talent I
observe it as well in your your new show
um oh yeah yeah brandemic well done
Jesus no no I but no but it was a one
it's wonderful I I watched all of the
clips I watched the trailer what you
managed to do in that show So for
anybody that doesn't know Russell has a
show called brandemic which is going to
be available for just two weeks from
June 25th which you can watch online
globally you can pre-order it now I
pre-ordered it and my partners
pre-ordered it so we're even though
we're gonna be watching on the same
screen so there's two pre-orders but
it's this wonderful confrontation of the
last couple of years of Our Lives mixed
with comedy at the heart of it with also
this this permeating really important
message underneath there somewhere which
you I think you use comedy and such a
wonderful way to
um if I may say
uh inject an important message into me
through the through the medium of humor
and it's it's a wonderful skill that
I've seen in some great comedians some
of you know Jimmy Carter to his credit
he's wonderful what he does he uses a
different form of Comedy but the form of
Comedy you use to address very important
subject matter is
genius it's very very hard to do and in
fact when I sat here with Jimmy he said
he's trying to do more of that I've seen
a few great comedians like the
Chappelle's of the world who I saw in
New York a couple of weeks ago and
um Aziz Ansari he's fantastic at that I
saw him at the store do that as well I
highly recommend everybody go and get
pre-order pandemic it'll only be
available for two weeks and if you go
check out the trailer and YouTube it is
[__] hilarious
um it confronts all the things a lot of
people are a bit too scared to confront
but with a real a real elegance and a
real class so thank you for that and
also
I have to mention Community which is an
event that's taking place
when is it July yeah July the 14th to
July is it polite for me to ask your
girlfriend's name Melanie Melanie
yeah come with Melanie she's we should
be right up her alleys there be at
Simpkins there Vandana Shiva proper
leaders both in political and spiritual
spaces because in the end these are fake
divisions there is only one space you'll
love it come come and do a turn on a
Saturday night I saw I saw a poster for
it and I thought this can't be real
because of the the people that are there
and they're all Gathering I thought it
can't be in person it must be online and
then I found out it was in person as
well so 14th of July to the 17th of July
um in hey on way why is there a river
that uh like that bifurcates England and
Wales or at least separates England and
Wales although actually England the
world's most conceptual so by the case
that bit of land that is currently
called England and Wales it's a reverse
on a campsite I went to during the
pandemic I went there on a holiday in a
one in Vans you know that you can do up
from within and we're such a lovely time
there and we did a small Festival last
year and this year we're doing a bigger
Festival and the money that we make we
give to people with addiction and mental
health issues various Charities that we
support for the stay free Foundation is
proper it's an attempt to live how we
might live
that that is probably the most
compelling thing to me because I
literally wrote a chapter in my book
called The Journey Back To Human and so
it's wonderful to see something called
Community that's doing exactly that
bringing us back to what it is to be a
human and as you say the cause is that
the proceeds of this event are going to
are phenomenal including a clothian
charity I believe which was that it's a
charity in Plymouth I think oh yeah yeah
yeah
Trevi women that's the only Treatment
Center we are in the country that is
able to take women with imp with
addiction issues and complex needs that
have kids already because obviously it's
very difficult to look after women that
are drug addicts that have kids and
stuff so that place though they do a
fantastic job down in your ends in
Plymouth my old neck of the woods so you
can heal yourself but also the proceeds
will help to heal others which I think
is a phenomenal thing so thank you for
that we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest leaves a
question for the next guest not knowing
who they're leaving it for
um
you can have a 60-second conversation
with anyone in your life but it is the
last conversation you will have with
them no I can't do this is all that's a
brilliant or evil question evil I always
tell the guests I say because they've
all been stitched up by the last
question so I say Stitch pay it forward
you know what you've already got to know
them and it's 60 seconds who
huge you call in what you say
well but the thing is is that bill can I
just break this down a bit you're
dispatching them after that yeah so it's
in a way and you have to know them is
that contained in the connection well
it's you can enter it's only 60 seconds
60 seconds and I've never seen him again
I mean there's no one in my life that I
love that I want to give up on that so
60 seconds I'm never gonna see him again
afterwards yeah
um God there's some good people that
I've met though I know because I'm going
to pluck Australia like a virtual
stranger
a virtual strange interesting because
why it's only 60 seconds you're letting
go of them oh no you're not I don't
think it means that you can never see
them again
I think the world interpreted it was you
run it's your last day on Earth you get
a phone call so it's getting worse then
there's no more me
oh my God this who wrote this question
some evil I'm joking um
you know tell us it's Anonymous
sometimes it so it'll eventually come
out on a card that people can play with
their friends
Hustler
every day all right um so just say
someone I love I'm going to talk to you
for 60 seconds yeah
[Music]
um
but and they're alive already you can't
even get someone that's dead back kind
of my name back I'd love a minute 100
I'll take my nan okay I'll take 60
seconds of me Nan I love you Nan I'm all
right I'm not so crazy you were right
about the drugs though why huh because
she was so lovely it's actually loved me
so much it was so unself-conscious it
was so unself-conscious oh you're right
darling shame in it a what level West
Kai Bush what's that drug she's doing
I'll tell you I see on Kilroy it'll lead
to worse things
60 Seconds
let her know you're okay
yes
you're okay yes
perfect
thank you Russell and honor to meet you
and thank you so much for being here you
could have been anywhere so I really
appreciate your time I really really
appreciate that thanks thank you thank
you thank you so much for having me it
was really
lovely intense experience the scenery
the environment's so gray and the
conversation is so colorful
intentionally I told you excellent oh
[Music]
quick one I'm so delighted that we're
now sponsoring this podcast I've worn a
week for a very very long time and there
are so many reasons why I became a
member but also now a partner and an
investor in the company but also me and
my team are absolutely obsessed with
data driven testing compounding growth
marginal gains all the things you've
heard me talk about on this podcast and
that very much aligns with the values of
whoop whoop provides a level of detail
that I've never seen with any other
device of this type before constantly
monitoring constantly learning and
constantly optimizing my routine for
providing me with this feedback we can
drive significant positive behavioral
change and I think that's the real
thesis of the business so if you're like
me and you are a little bit obsessed or
focused on becoming the best version of
yourself from a health perspective
you've got to check out woob and the
team that we've kindly given us the
opportunity to have one month's free
membership for anyone listening to this
podcast just go to join.woop.com CEO to
get your whoop 4.0 device and claim your
free month and let me know how you get
on as you know they're a sponsor of the
podcast and I'm one of the investors in
the company my relationship with Hill
started with the ready to drink range
which I have here in front of me on the
table why did I choose to drink this
first and foremost convenience I'm not
the type of person that wants to spend a
huge amount of time whisking or mixing
things together and I don't typically
have a huge amount of time during the
day and there are some days not always
but there are some days where because of
the limited amount of time I have the
choices that I would ordinarily reach
for aren't necessarily the most healthy
choices they're certainly not
nutritionally complete so as soon as I
discovered who all existed because of a
wonderful guy who worked one of my teams
in Manchester walked past me wearing a
heel t-shirt I inquired what it was he
told me what it was and then I bought
the ready to drink bottles into the
office it was a game changer for me and
it meant that on those days where I'm
tempted to reach for Less nutritionally
complete options or less healthy food
options I have something right
underneath my desk in the fridge that I
can reach for that allows me to remain
in line with my health and nutrition
goals and Tesco have now increased their
listings with hewell so you can now get
the RTD ready to drink in Tesco
expresses all across the UK
[Music]
oh
foreign